I'm Dave Brailsford I'm the team
principal of Team Sky and trying to
oversee everything and hopefully keep a
keep an eye on everything but I'm really
interested in how science and technology
can inform and improve human performance
and that's my passion and hence why I'm
interested in all aspects of you know
psychology science nutrition and all
those areas first and foremost when you
look at all of our partners obviously
the bikes are very very important the
parts of what we do
clothing is an important part of what we
do but equally nutrition is one of the
most fundamental parts of what we do and
we take it very very seriously we invest
a lot of time now trying to understand
the sort of latest thinking and
developments in the whole world of
nutrition which is changing you know by
day by day really so when we when we
step back and think about what we want
from a nutritional partner we want
certainly we've always got to be able to
trust the processes as systems make sure
that the the manufacturing process if
you like is robust I think it goes
without saying but equally we want to
work with a partner who's flexible who
can adapt their products no gimmicks you
know just like prop elite performance
products that we can use to make sure
that the guys are fuel properly before a
race fueled and hydrated during a race
obviously and then have the ability to
recover optimally and go again the next
day and it's a dynamic part of our sport
really the nutrition element because
it's changing there's a lot of a lot of
new ideas coming in you know we've gone
very much away from the old plates of
places spaghetti and carbs all the time
to the introduction of some quite
sophisticated thinking around protein
the timing of when we eat the FASTA
dries how they fit into what we do and
then like I say the role of how do we
manage body composition in an optimal
way and without having the right partner
with the right products it's just it's
just not possible so that's why we chose
sa